you want witty dialogue you wanted 10
stories and you want a couple of what
was that moment you're talking about boo
one of the best working today
it's Quentin Tarantino every time this
guy puts out a movie you are blown out
of your socks on January 1st
Tarantino released a highly anticipated
hateful eight and in honor of City today
we'll be choosing the greatest Tarantino
moments to see before you see a plate
number eight Jackie Brown the scene is
called three minutes later Robert DeNiro
and Bridget Fonda star in the scene
which they seem they're having a really
nice dialogue they're getting to know
each other
Bridget Fonda says one fun at Bridget
father catches us off guard as much as
she catches the near off-guard then it's
the most Awkward sex scene you're ever
going to see number seven death proofs
car crash you watch the scene and you
watch the girls talk about the WHO and
you know that Tarantino wrote it
Tarantino is the ultimate b-movie fan
and he's a film purist so when the
ladies in the car crash go out they go
out and style whoops that goes her face
number six a jackrabbit slim from pulp
fiction
music I would love to see Tarantino's
iTunes list the guy just picks random
songs and the next thing you know they
are characters in the movie Travolta was
in Greece and Saturday Night Fever so
you know he's had all you know what I
had to do here man and he made sure that
he had Travolta do a nice little dance
with Huma Thurmond make sure that he
showed him the Thurman's feet and the
rest is history
number five Kill Bill Vol to Superman
let's get back to that dialogue
Tarantino knows how to knock you on your
ass with some mind-blowing dialogue take
an example when bill gives the bride has
breakdown a Superman and the way that
Superman sees the human race it's a
unique perspective that once heard Clark
Kent is Superman's critique whole human
race Wow
I have never looked at it that way yes
Superman finds us pathetic and number
four Reservoir Dogs the dinner scene
like a virgin who besides Tarantino can
take a bunch of criminals you sit them
down at a table and have them
made exactly what the classic Madonna
song like a virgin is really about it's
funny insightful and what would have to
believe the Tarantino has had this
conversation before
add it to the scene and delivered
himself
hence the fridge and number three
Reservoir Dogs
stuck in the middle with you you've seen
the movie you know what I'm talking
about you get scared Michael Madsen is
terrifying as he's torturing officer
Nash the enjoyment in the song is used
absolutely brilliantly number two Pulp
Fiction
Ezekiel Sam Jackson has been a staple in
Tarantino movies and that's because
Tarantino knows how to showcase
Jackson's talents there isn't a better
example than the opening scene in Pulp
Fiction when Jules recites his favorite
passage from the Bible
it's that lead-up to the passage that
sets you up to exactly who Jews is I
will strike down upon thee with great
vengeance and furious anger now the
number one moment for me is an
inglorious basterds it's the opening
Christoph Waltz plays the Jew hunter he
is looking for some people but we don't
really know that yet just to scare the
[ __ ] out of us that's exactly what he
does and it works nicely it is a scene
where people around me we're sweating
you will remember that because you feel
like you are there this has been the
eighth greatest Tarantino moments thanks
for watching Fandango movie clips
I'm Kristian harloff you can find me
watching hatefully
you